we're live we're just in professional exactly we don't we're not waiting for an intro technically you can think that the intro played already for like for like four minutes if you think about it because i started five minutes late the intro played in all our heads the intro was playing in our hearts chat it was there by default yeah yeah exactly you we were all clapping along to Yeah,
my chow's in it.
Live now.
We're actually finishing this game.
Yes, we're finishing.
Apparently we were like 60% already.
60%?
Yeah, it's a short game.
It's technically a short game.
Is it a short game where we just played that long?
No, we played like three hours, didn't we?
Like, games back then in 2000s were really short because they were not $80.
They were...
yeah they were not it feels like it's 80 i'm pretty sure yeah well it's 80 now it's 80 dollars i don't even remember wait how much is here so wait let me check actually how much is now that steam is not crashing because of silk song imagine if you're not you don't even know about silk song and you try it you're just on steam trying to download something and during the great silk song crash they're like oh it's 50 dollars holy what the end though wait retail price for gears of war original how much was the original gears of war hell i don't remember all three of the original titles are on sale now of gold for okay that's like okay that's when it was on sale guys how much how much was the original gears of war for retail you can buy gears of war on the xbox 360 for 23 dollars the original xbox game 23 23 Canadian dollars so I'm just like wondering how much was it retail like when it first came out though it was $60 Canadian okay that wasn't so bad $60 Canadian that's pretty all right
like oh wait but then to account for inflation that's like more than 80.
if you think about it yeah I would guess so i would be if you count for inflation that is actually more than 80 dollars like i could just buy a mario crate like i remember black ops 2 were like around 60 or 55 dollars i thought they used to be 40 dollars back then i didn't realize they were 60 old dollars what that's crazy for that for that agent holy crap like 68 hey man wait i'm in a back-end country no i mean like No,
60 US for you or Indonesian.
I'd have it.
Should be around that.
Yeah, I'm saying.
I thought they were like $40 back then.
I didn't realize they were that expensive.
And why were we completing anything about $80?
If we account for inflation.
Because like, then that's just inflation, right?
Because I feel like if we account for inflation, it would, and it makes sense it's $80.
$80 is in...
If you account for inflation, okay what is what is sixty dollars inflate oh your wage oh wait sorry wages didn't increase to i forgot i forgot wages never increased yeah wages never kept up i'm thinking because like for inflation um for inflation i think about movie ticket sales because that's why people like to account for like prices you how they're like oh if the titanic came out in 2025 it would have made x amount of money so i like think like that but i forgot like wages never increased though they're still the same wages increase yeah i know they do minimum wage will still be the same after 50 years to learn more about the same since 10 years to learn more about years of war inflation you should years of war inflation
what's a sonic inflation uh it was when like sonic used to be cheaper back then in uh 2000 and if you want to know like the exact number you should google sonic inflation inflation is it stated in the rule 34 well well it was originally in rule 69 but they moved it to rule 34 because they felt like it was a better They felt like this this specific rule regarding like the inflation of prices on Sonic mattered more How can you say this in a straight face?
It's because I am a professional gaslighter Yeah, all right, I forgot about that I am a professional gaslighter.
Okay, I have a lot of experience and I am also he has been very bratty lately He he interrupted my spot stream because you were watching my sponsor stream right for a while yeah so I was like oh my god he got closer he walked up to my door yeah it got so much louder he walked up to my door so um he interrupted because I was with Tim to tap man and ninja and obviously I couldn't I had to mute myself because I didn't want them to hear my fucking dog barking and so like I have to ignore him because he's kind of like he'll win um so you're gonna have to put up with this what what what um basically um he like was barking because he wanted food early but he wanted food at like three p.m yeah at three p.m i was like he wanted his lunch his dinner at three p.m because he already had his regular,
he already had lunch.
So he wanted his dinner at 3 p.m.
and he walked away because I closed the door on him.
Yeah, the worst thing is my door isn't an actual door.
It's like a glass plane.
So like there's like glass in the center.
So like, like, like he just, he just look at me through the glass.
He's just peeking through that.
Yeah, he can just look at me.
He knows what's going on inside the room.
Oh, look at the man's food.
So it doesn't even...
do anything yeah so so i had to feed so he won because i had to feed him at 3 p.m because i was like i needed i can't just stop because i'm nearly sponsored to be on that stream so like like there was nothing i could do and i didn't want to fucking like bother the stream like bothered the sponsor right you're sponsored and he isn't like he wins he gets to have anything he wants he knows true he knows too he's like you can't do anything about it i can still hear yeah he is he's like he's just barking from from like his bed right now i don't know what he's barking about he's he's he's had food his water bowl is filled up he's literally just barking because he wants more food that's really good because he's a pig yeah he loves to eat he's like food he's food motivated but the thing is he never wants the food to stop he doesn't he thinks that like the food should never stop like you you take that back how much does he weigh um well he got like really he got really fat um when i was on my
business trip because um he was on steroids uh for like because okay not because like i wanted him to get jacked up or anything uh it was for a medical reason okay it's not because i wanted my dog to have a fucking six pack but he had to be on steroids because um he uh sprained uh he had like a small disc issue around his neck area so like they're like oh we shouldn't do surgery we should just let him recover so i gave him to the dog sitter because i also had a business trip to for the marvel rivals stuff and and then so they gave him steroids to help with recovery so he'll his like his like front paw his front legs would be stronger hell yeah yes and then apparently so apparently no the side effect is that he gets like like he he puts on more weight so when i like first got him back he was there like times to the size and when i dropped him off yeah so i was like oh my god he's so like thick now and i think he's like and also like my dog sitter spoils him she like sent me a picture
like oh i got i got him up i got dad a bone and it is like a the bone is like half his size yeah it's like so like yeah so so like the dog said it would give him like lots of treats and like um special food other than his like actual food so um so it's like he He misses that.
He's like, he's, he like, every time, um, he knows whenever it's dog sitting time.
Cause he like, what?
So he's just spoiled now.
Yeah, he's so spoiled.
Whenever, when I, when I picked him up, the last time I picked, like when I picked him up after my business trip, and a dog sitter got in his, got in their car.
He like looked back at her and tried to run to the car and was like, why are you leaving?
Like, he's like, wait, no, no, wait.
Let me in the car too.
Where do you want?
He's so spoiled.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Give me a second.
I'm gonna hold him.
Oh man.
I don't think I could ever take care of a dog.
Man.
All right.
It's in my arms right now.
You're just tapping him or is it just his tail he's been he's getting yeah he won he has won again he has won yet again yeah now he's on my yeah he won this little brat yeah i don't know where he gets this from i'm i'm weak i know i'm weak and we have to play god of war
all right so tension i both forgot the controls yeah i we i just i know this i remember the story like we blew up the locust nest but we didn't actually blow it up kind of failed yeah and then we missed kim we still do miss kim still miss him yeah we still think about him we go to his grave like every every year we go to his grave leave flowers yeah leave flowers It's for me,
it's before I sleep.
You know, it's before he's, oh, every, oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Tengen really misses Kim.
He, Kim always told...
I can't open a door.
Kim always told us, like, Tengen was his very special friend.
If there were to be a door in front of me, I'd have to stare at it for, like, 11 minutes.
And then hope I'd get teleported behind it afterwards.
Yeah, yeah.
It was not fair.
Like, Tengen always gets, like, the special meanings.
after after school uh i go counseling yeah yeah it's not fair i understand how come you get to be like his special friend and get all the special treatment no i i'm in a special class
okay we're in game okay
what am i saying in the morning oh yeah it's like 8 a.m it's like history will say they were really good it's just loads for you like when prompted press the use button curb stop a down enemy it's just loading on the loading gear for me because i'm in the game right now why are you in i'm literally just loading where am i oh my god tell me when you're in Okay,
this is actual player two.
Player two.
Where are my rights?
Okay, you're positive.
I'm in.
All right.
Okay.
All right, let's go.
I'm putting this dog.
We ended in a fight.
I just remember we ended in a fight.
Oh, shit.
I'm putting my dog down on the floor.
Ah!
You're putting your dog down.
Okay, no.
He's like looped up on my wires just now.
All right, I'm ready, player two.
All right.
I'm in.
I think he unplugged my headphones.
Oh Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, I can hear you.
I was I muted my game You didn't say anything, so I was so confused.
Okay, it's okay.
How do I play yet?
I'm getting shot by a lot.
Okay, no, you're not you're fine No, I'm trying to figure out how to play this game.
Give me a sec.
How do you?
Wait, everybody said we did it No, they're not they're still shooting.
I'm I did it you did it why let me go i'm doing it wait how do i how do i melee again you remember f okay oh i can order walk oh god okay wait okay my shajab no all right if you press crouch you start aura walking uh crouching is space okay crouching is space yeah it is oh my god he's doing it again i oh my god he's he's still doing it he's he's winning okay nice where's my audio my audio's disappearing all right we're fine we're fine i'm more walking are we fine i'm more walking yeah is there straight from walking while shooting like what the fuck is this oh i jabbed my car i might jab my gun there's a bow watch out oh shit oh nice We're five.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I'm going to grab the ammo.
Nice.
It's the boom guy.
He just says boom, my friend.
I forgot it is.
Boom, man.
Nice.
Boom.
Wait, how do you throw grenades again?
Oh, there's another one.
Oh, where is he?
Okay.
Oh, shit.
I'm getting sniped.
He's not saying boom.
He's saying boom.
Why is he looking at you?
He's looking at me.
He's looking at you.
He doesn't know.
There you go.
Wait, how do you, so how do you make that again?
F?
I think.
Okay, yeah, it's F.
It is.
What the fuck is this room?
I'm revving it up.
I don't know.
Okay, I gotta, no, give me that ammo.
It's easy.
God damn it.
I have no idea what he's barking about, too.
That's the worst part.
It's a little muted because I closed the door.
He'll get tired.
Don't worry.
He'll get tired eventually.
It's like a hyperactive kid.
Yeah, he'll tie himself up.
Or not.
It'll happen eventually.
Okay, bring the game up a little more.
Okay, I forgot to say, sorry, I paused it.
Oh wait, it does not pause.
God damn, I forgot.
It's a choice.
I forgot.
You get like...
Left path and right path.
So I'm assuming which one do you want to go?
I want to go...
I want to go... wait.
I want to go left because it's inside and I have a shotgun.
take right yeah well then control will take both bared you're with me hold dom take the building and cover our back all right i believe in us i'm with baron again god damn it he would never have rights we have an all we have is an unplugged controller don't worry i hear boom guy above me I'm a little worried actually Wait,
where are they?
There's nobody in here.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, it's bow guy.
It's bow guy.
It's one shot bow man He lives with me.
Oh, no, it's the bow man.
Oh shit.
He blew up.
Holy crap.
They're just not buying.
Wait, what's the okay?
I want to try and use that actually How do I use that?
I'm gonna try it out.
Oh yeah, no, this is, I'm not trying it out.
I'm giving me my gun back.
Yeah, like, where did my gun go?
Sorry.
You're gonna be fighting everything right now.
I'm still trying to find my gun.
Where did my gun go?
Wait.
Oh my god, move!
Oh, it's a cedar.
It's the big spider thing.
Alright, don't worry.
Do you have a hammer or something?
Please.
Don't worry.
I'm grabbing ammo.
I'm heading over for real now.
Don't worry.
I'm helping.
You see me?
Do you see me?
You see me helping you shooting the gun right now?
Do you have a hand?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm helping.
I'm helping.
I'm shooting him right now.
Don't worry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I am.
I'm literally right there.
Look up.
I can throw grenades in there.
Ah, my shit's jam.
God damn.
On your roof.
it's okay i'm shooting himself yeah yeah that's great confidence
i don't think i can shoot it man i don't i don't think there's a ray gun i ask there's just little guys here that's it
i'm not doing any damage i'm i'm looking around and there's nothing up here that says that i can do anything for you are you sure are you sure you can't kill him yourself i mean there's no red indication i'm assuming i'm not doing any damage to it if i over it okay that's fine i don't know oh so you're wasting him i see blood if blood comes out i think i'm doing that oh it's over here i found it oh nice finally please do job don't worry i got i'm doing job oh yeah apparently i've walked past it like four times oh wait i should whoops i was getting shot at um someone was not protecting me um can you get his oh it's because i stood next to the ray gun the laser like burned me thank you it only works at daytime type of thing where is my shotgun is my shotgun yeah he's still outside my door he's not giving up oh sorry i was distracted because i was trying to find my gun i don't have a bomb oh no we're here we're gonna do it all over again attention i have a job to close up a hole man it
was all the bold person man i can't believe it i thought you were a gamer Yeah.
No, I'm not.
I am not a gamer enough to do this.
You were literally in a tournament like yesterday.
Last night.
Okay, last night.
Okay, I'm heading over.
I am getting going over to kill the extra guys before I can.
Before I can grab the ray gun.
There's...
Okay.
So Hammer of Dawn is like...
Okay, I can also die too.
Oh my god, I actually have to I actually have to heal.
Give me a sec He's not backing down.
I know He's not giving up I admire his tenacity the worst part is that There's so much people with the bow man.
Okay.
I'm almost there.
I just need a I need to kill the little guys before I can do the rain gun All right, I got it.
I got the rain gun.
You got this?
How the fuck?
Okay, why is he here?
I don't have any need.
All right, ready?
I'm gonna do it.
Please.
He's not back and down.
I'm still doing it.
Wait, why is it not working?
Oh, there it is.
There you go.
I did it.
Okay, where's my shotgun?
Oh, there it is.
I'll take that.
Oh!
I'm okay.
You just got to live now.
Your mission is to just live.
The audio is so weird.
I'm hearing footsteps and everything.
And you're also hearing my dog barking.
Yeah, so it doesn't help at all.
He'll never...
He'll never know what to do.
I'll never...
I'll be...
I'll be very confused.
We can't give in.
It's okay.
He'll get tired eventually.
of dawn is offline all right i'm turning the cog
door i am doing it as fast as i can no thank you why does it open so slowly look look it's the gears okay of war of war yeah it was never meant to be fast okay but gears rotate yeah but it's a very big gear so So it's harder to rotate.
Is it a metal gear?
Yeah, it's very solid.
It's surprisingly very solid for a metal gear.
It's not like...
It's not like liquid, you know?
Yeah.
Yeah, like a snake.
Like a snake.
There's a sniper right there.
Oh god, this fucking thing.
Why is it so loud, man?
is it so loud i forgot how loud the game audio in this game oh yeah yeah also sound guy i up the game volume already let me know oh there's a frag grenade here um oh wait oh it's just nice i need frag grenades how do you how do you grenades yeah where okay all right i'm downstairs now i can help i'm helping oh i'm reloading i'm reloading
all right nice i take all that i swear to god it like if we have to redo this entire thing what the hell some hiding in a cover where are you on the other side oh oh hey dom wait where are you oh you're on the other side can you even get here you even get here i'm I'm gonna run to the inside.
Hold on.
And your voice is gone for some reason.
Hello?
Hello!
Can you hear me?
She gone?
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Okay, I forgot that what?
Oh my god, you started the game.
I was in the middle of the road.
Okay, I forgot I had pushed the mute.
Wait, pause the game.
I had pushed the mute.
Okay.
I pressed one.
I forgot.
I had pushed a mute for my earlier stream.
Okay.
Let me.
Oh my God.
Here you go.
You have pushed me on one?
Because I couldn't use my mouse button.
Because one was for...
One was for I need healing.
And the other one was melee.
What?
Yes.
I put my mouse button for I need healing.
Because it's efficient.
Also press start and pause the game.
Player one.
Okay.
Here you go.
Where am I talking?
There's literally a...
fight in front of me still oh my god he's still going he's okay no okay wait i'm i'm give me a sec i i can't okay i'm gonna scold him give me a oh my god the moment i went to look at him he ran away he had he ran away from the door i think i think your dog has some he knew he knew he he yeah oh wait that's that's the enemy He literally scurried away.
If I knew I just had to do that.
Oh my god, now he's barking from a forest.
Okay.
Oh my, they're still like the turret guy.
I can't see the third guy yet.
He's like too much.
Okay.
I'm trying to shoot him, but he has so much HP.
Jesus.
okay nice we got him how do i jam a revolver what the heck just like you always do where do we go why why he's still working what what no no no no no no no
okay oh my gosh he's been so bratty he's like okay he wasn't that bad yesterday but like today I don't know today just feels like he feels spoiled yeah today he feels like he feels like today is his special day there you go are we supposed to be here I don't know today is a special day oh yeah you do
that oh I'm going downstairs are we regrouping finally is that oh wait that's the X that X-box achievements sold out wow yeah I got the X-box achievement Crap Oh, I shot at our people.
Oops.
I shot at them.
It looked like enemies.
Why is it always people wearing helmets?
It is always.
They don't have rights.
That's why they're faceless.
Go ahead, clear the way.
You catch up when you can.
Traveling Conservatory.
This is Delta 1.
Delta 2 is caring for wounded and flagging for pickup.
Is it conservatory clear?
Then that's all you're shaking hips.
It's so loud, you know?
Shakira, Shakira.
Oh my god, finally peace at last.
Vaude Watchers skip 30 minutes.
Vaude Watchers skips 30 minutes.
For him to stop.
Guys, look, I won.
There'll be a timestamp.
of where your dog stops barking completely i won i should have done that earlier i should have been like no earlier i just thought he'll give up but he did not give up he sadly was very persistent he has been defeated the evil the evil board said you know he's such a bully he's like such a Like,
there was a very tiny dog.
There was a very tiny dog.
Like, it's, like, it's like small, like those teacup dogs, you know?
Mm-hmm.
And then it was minding its own business, just, like, walking the streets.
And he tried, if he was not, like, leashed up, it wasn't, like, um...
With his harness and everything.
He, like, tried to run straight at him.
Like, hold on, like, ran, try to run straight at the tiny teacup dog and, like, barked at him, too.
And this was two days ago, and I was like, I am so...
sorry like inappropriate public behavior yeah he was not he his like attitude got like super bratty the last couple of days and then like and then he like and then some guy was like running next to him and he got he was he freaked out he's like what are you doing running next to me yeah it's the roids as a roid oh no oh yeah i think he has roid rage honestly he definitely does he went to prison no it's from because he got roided up i would not be surprised is this i is that what sarah words does he just get he's just mad i i think i guess who this no i don't know never had one At least he...
I don't know.
Never had steroids.
Never had one.
I don't even know if it's legal here or not.
It should be legal.
Steroids.
It's just that steroids is an actual medication.
But, like, people just abused it to get extra buff.
To get a sport advantage.
I'm just...
I can see where he is.
It's, like, right next to me.
Alright.
You go handle this.
Why?
hand of this i'll be right back you can do it i believe in you what if there's a boom guy what
god damn it it's the longest door cutting ever why are they even shooting it
huh like what
it's just one guy and apparently he's stuck wait what happened The AI stuck.
Wait, what?
We're okay.
Oh, what the heck?
Boomers!
Oh, shit, not the...
Okay, wait, it's fine.
Boom!
I'm permanent.
Well, then okay.
Dom, let's drop the hammer.
Boom!
Nice.
I got a headshot.
Oh, God.
Did you have...
Is that your...
What?
A gun is a gun.
Nice.
Nice shot.
It would be crazy if you missed that shot.
Not gonna lie.
It's a laser pointer.
How do you miss a laser pointer?
That's what I'm saying.
It would be crazy if you missed.
How would you miss a laser pointer?
It's like pinpointing a presentation.
Oh, yeah, there's only two of us now.
God damn it.
Wait, there's only two of us?
No.
Players three and four.
You were never real.
It was all in their heads.
The fuck was that?
Okay, you said something.
I vaguely remember this.
What do I vaguely remember this?
I don't know anything.
Oh, hey, there's ammo.
Oh, there's another ray.
Is it what I think it is?
Does the ray require ammo?
Because you can grab one right now.
No, it's just a cooldown.
I like my gun.
You know what?
no i want to keep my chainsaw how do we get out of here probably this one oh nice i don't know vaguely remember this i don't know resident evil person evil has an area like this where it's just grass where where is it not like this yeah i was gonna say it's always it's always grass in red despite everything being an undead somehow there's plants they love plants i guess I mean,
it's probably a good source of protein, though.
That's true.
Plants are technically zombies.
True.
Is their brain dead?
Oh, shit!
That's why.
Oh, fuck.
It's new, snooze.
It's...
Wait, it's okay.
She can't get past here.
It's okay.
We have a barrier between her and us.
See?
It's okay.
She can't get here.
I can't use the hammer down here.
There's a roof.
Oh, okay.
It's okay.
We can run past it.
We can run past it now.
She gone.
Goodbye, Tengen.
I'll always remember your heroic acts.
Woo!
I'll always remember what you did for us.
Whoa!
God, oh, freak!
What happened?
He roars through a wall like a cool-aid.
He did a cool-aid guy.
He was a cool-aid guy.
Oh, wait, wait.
Distractive.
Don't come here.
Oh, never mind.
I thought.
He's... Oh, my God.
I... Is he supposed to break this?
Oh, he's supposed to break the pillars.
The pillars.
Affirmative.
Pillars?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, the pillars.
You're smart.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Break all the pillars.
He wants... She wants your snoo-snoo-s-snoo.
Running out of time.
get the fuck over here yo um take her out on a day first tangent oh my god no
all right you're almost there you have like four more to do i believe in you you got this yeah you got this tangent i'm watching you we have a cinematic perspective Oh my god, why did you come over here?
Why did you come over here?
She wanted you.
Oh, last one, last one says you.
Please.
No, nothing happens.
That was as far as my plan was gonna go.
Oh no, there's one more.
There's one more pillar.
We forgot one more pillar.
There's one more on the other side.
There's two more.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, sorry.
I can't count.
You got this.
Come on.
I believe.
Yo.
Go, Tengen, go.
Oh, you missed.
Oh, come on, Tengen.
Why?
How could you miss that?
That was the most obvious.
Okay, now I don't...
I think we might be stuck, though, after that.
There's an open wall.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
She cool-a-a-de-ed.
Oh, I can't...
We're stuck here.
We are stuck here.
Why did you?
Oh my god.
Tension, you did the... Oh my god.
Okay.
We are alive.
We are.
Oh my god.
It's open.
Some of the walls are open.
Okay.
Some of the roofs are open.
We did it.
Now use your ray.
Now use your fucking ray.
Stop running.
Okay.
Yeah.
I could totally just stop that.
we did it we're a hero oh my god okay all right we're in this the cool down end oh my god boom die nice we did it now watch no oh shit whoa okay i'm gonna help i'll help you i'll help oh wait oh you got it okay i'll help you don't worry boom i'm here there we go yeah yeah all right she should die now what is here thank god now we can do this how do i do this how about you never do that space space keep pressing space yeah not so fast now what is it yeah it's very hard to do it fast yeah it's a difficult job yeah turning a gear yeah i should be paid more than minimum they're just that weak maybe i should take some steroids yeah maybe you should take some right get roided up oh i'm jabbed my revolver i put i put like i know there's something because you guys said shit like you jabbed the revolver yeah i put too many bullets in my revolver i like grabbed a handful and just stuffed it in it's a shot oh shit oh yeah nice nice we made a hole yay wait where's the hole oh is that that thing's
coming over no i mean i can throw it are you sure that's a hole oh shit okay i'll throw this hole somewhere i thought okay yeah you got it too never mind yeah you definitely got it yep what's that do you hear that not my dog but like i thought it was your dog no no no i'm not talking about my dog i'm talking about the enemies i mean there's a lot of things all right nice over here hammer of dawn is offline hammer of dawn is online what am i supposed to pay your money paying for excuse me my tax my taxes should go to wars of mass destruction like who decided put my tax paying my tax dollars in a school this should be for my for my bullets I am at war right now that's it we got our cut funding for more schools it's not we need our rate we need our satellite glazer oh i might die so yeah i'm shooting him i think yeah he's taking damage more defending now just blind shooting nice a headshot is that all all right no i'm getting shot at it where over here like this one guy behind that bench
you see him he's literally that's why can't i shoot a freaking bench through the bench don't worry he can't hurt you no more our revolver should pierce through the bench not gonna lie okay they're all like any gun should go through that bench yeah that bench is not made out of a very strong material no exactly they should triple the defense budget out.
Travel the defense budget.
Hello?
Oh shit, it's boom boom.
Wait, where is he?
Where?
Without my hammer of dawn?
Oh, he's right here.
Oh, no, no, we're on the bench.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm literally at the, oh my god, I stood still.
Where is he going?
To me?
You.
Ah!
He's dead.
Nice.
I peeked out.
My, the hammer of dawn is offline i'm just gonna swap yeah you might as well i'm okay for those who are wondering i swear to god if it goes online immediately after it is i mean you can just walk back just walk back and grab your gun nice nice oh god oh wait it was bait it was bait it was just jump scare it see it was bait it was a bait yeah It was a very poor attempt at jump scare.
Where do we?
Do we just go this way?
I guess we leave where we came from.
Oh, it's this door, I think.
Wait, boom.
What?
Are you sure?
Can you kick a door?
I don't think I can.
Oh, I can.
I think that's true.
Oh, what the fuck is this room?
I think he was like having some freaky time with that body.
We like interrupted something.
we literally interrupted something yeah
oh yeah i think so there's the archer man wait i'm sucking up fucking it i was sucking up random i'd see where we watched him right away random pan action yeah i'm just walking away i'm like what where the fuck did he go where did he go he ran so far away holy shit i swear i swear he was walking away was he not yeah attack with you he said attack there's a lot of with him it's fine i have a i have a revolver just you have a revolver six shots yeah i mean i had shot that i didn't had shot that one i didn't have that one it'll happen watch this oh they have a shotgun they'll You killed the guy I was trying to headshot.
So, like, what's the point?
They'll all of them have a shotgun.
Yeah, and I was trying to headshot.
I was trying to get my clip here for my YouTube.com.
Oh.
He's reloading.
You think this land post?
Yeah, this land post is definitely great cover.
All right, let's go.
Oh, there's more shotgun ammo.
There's a boom shot.
I do.
Yeah, I need to grab this ammo.
like this boomshot crosshair like what is this crosshair it doesn't make any sense where we go engine you're the you're the guide i'm probably here you're my sherpa sure but yeah yeah yeah sure for me you know that um like so many people do mount everest class like now now there's like a line to the the height mount everest you will die no there's literally a line and then like and then like the really rich will have their Sherpas like like uh carry them to the top and give them like piggyback rise to the top or they like get like they sit on a cart like a little snow like board thing and have the Sherpas like pull them up because they couldn't do that on their on their own what because they're like I climb out because they can like tweet out how and take a picture of how they climb Mount Everest and like and like flex it to people why I know because they want it they're rich they're rich they're rich i can't quit you dom yeah that's from uh what's it called brookback mountain why
can't i quit you dom you know brookback mountain oh rocket mountain you know brookback mountain have you ever watched brookback mountain the old movie yeah do you know what it is about the one that like brother and sister missing on the freaking mountain so she's like Yeah,
yeah, it's actually really good.
It won like a couple of Oscars.
I watched that like a couple of times already.
Yeah, really?
What's your favorite part about Brokeback?
Yeah, what's your favorite part?
I don't know.
I don't remember Jack.
Yeah, no, it has like a really good scene with the, where like they're being chased by, because it's like a little bit of like a horror movie too.
You remember that part in Brokeback Mountain?
No, I don't remember anything.
When you don't remember, it was like a little bit of a horror section in there.
Like you think, and then you're like, it's like a little plot twist.
And then you found out, like, the sister is actually adopted.
What?
Oh, is that a horror part?
No, no, like, because, like, during, like, it's, no, I didn't mean that was a horror part.
They were being chased around the mountain.
Because they all, they went to hike at Brokeback Mountain.
to hike at Brokeback Mountain, brother and sister, because their parents used to have like a cabin there.
And in that cabin, they found out that the sister was adopted.
Are you sure you watched Brokeback Mountain?
Like, what the fuck?
Like, you said you watched it several times!
You said you watched it several times!
I just know something about Mountain.
I don't know exactly what.
Okay, what do you remember about Brokeback Mountain?
Nothing particular.
Like, is there anything that you remember other than the fact that...
I'm gonna be out of here, too.
I'm the type of guy who would watch anime and then forget the episode that I watched yesterday.
It's like a fucking Oscar movie.
I know, but it applies to anything.
Like, oh yeah, I played the campaign.
What did you remember?
Try to remember one thing from Brookbat Mountain.
Because you say you used to watch it with your mom all the time, right?
Good to go.
One thing.
Can I remember one thing?
Well, about me watching it with my mom?
No, about the movie.
Because you watched this.
Yeah, hell no, I wouldn't remember that.
What did you remember?
What do you remember?
Other than the mountain.
Me shitting myself?
Why?
Because of the horror part?
No, I had a diarrhea.
Oh, you...
So you don't remember the chase scene in Brokeback Mountain, where they're being chased on the mountain.
not at all i am like especially horrors right i don't remember horrors yeah but it wasn't it was like a drama it was like it was mostly a drama movie though so like so it's like basically it was like i remember it was like a brother and sister and they were like they went to the cabin yeah and then they went to the cabin just remember that they were brothers yeah but then how could you forget the main plot where like the sister was actually not his sister because like his parents cheated like the mom cheated on the dad you actually don't remember why is it why why is that the problem no because it was just that was really good because i wanted oscar anyway brookbeck mount is actually about gay cowboys and i was fucking with you
brookbeck my mouth is actually about gay cowboys it was not about it was not even there was no brother and sister you're so there was not it wasn't even about brother and sister it was about two i remember i remember watching some movie about something about like my mom with my mom i don't remember anything that's like that's what chad my chad was like he watched it with his mom
oh that's not it was there there were some explicit scenes about these gay cowboys all right but yeah it's a different set of mountains all right where do we go uh that way probably probably why can't we cross that what the is this is just it's just these kind of rubbles like why why can't we swim can we not swim because we're too we're too we're too bugged our muscles our muscles will cause us to sink into the ocean they start getting naked at like the third installment oh yeah sweet i wish for the fans it's the fan service yeah yeah tangent oh what the fuck you see that guy yeah wait you're talking you think he knows you don't need to not die stop that how do we not never look at what no okay that's a point-blank grenade i know it's like holy shit he did oh my god oh he shot the ground and let's oh apparently they're really resilient in higher difficulty so they'll have like they actually just have more they're just more tough more health more damage it's like beef jerky is it is it
that what hard difficulty is supposed to be i mean that makes sense they're they always do yeah they just like they just make them into what do we just tell them yeah i know what the we open the door why can't we just go seamless oh i think it's because it's a loading screen back then yeah what's going on probably well there's a bunch of ass you can't be bothered to make it seamless um that's for when they re-release this game a fifth time Oh,
there they are.
What?
Oh, shit.
Here they come.
I don't even see where they are.
They're above us.
All right, he's going to peek, right?
He's peeked.
He's going to boom.
Boom.
Is that all?
Oh, oh, my God.
You lived that?
I need ammo.
Not now.
I dodged that.
Whoa.
Yeah, exactly.
some awkward place it's okay i'm okay boom boom my gun jam boom oh yeah he's dead there's a guy literally turret i need ammo what i was about to take that from you there's a there's a there's a assault rifle here there's more boom here no i already there's an assault rifle ammo i'm okay i'm Okay.
All right.
I'm going to boom.
I'm going to boom this guy in the back.
There's a guy literally behind you that's just chasing you.
What's with the AIs, man?
He's been chasing you the entire time.
Boom.
Is he going to, okay, he missed.
Oh, God.
All right.
Boom.
Yeah, I'll take that.
Up there.
Wait, I'm trying.
Oh my god, you started to cutscene, so I couldn't grab the ammo.
That's crazy.
Why is there a cutscene?
I don't know where.
Inside the house, there might be locust tunnels inside.
Copy that, Anya.
We are aware.
Oh my god, my wire is like snagged in my...
Oh, they're here.
Oh no.
What's up, ladies?
Locust.
Is it the A-train?
There's something else here too.
An APC behind the house.
Oh my god, my head was stuck on my bed.
No offense.
Ah.
No.
It's in the wheels.
Stop barking and my wires stuck on my chair wheels.
I'm a mess.
The dog's still barking.
Oh my god.
Okay, you gotta protect me.
I gotta fix my wires.
Why?
This stream's a mess.
There's nothing, so we're chilling.
I got this dungeon!
Yeah, I got you covered.
Oh my god, it's stuck, stuck.
I accidentally...
Okay.
I actually rolled my wires.
Okay, I got it.
I got it and I got a t-shirt.
I am going to tag.
Stop barking.
You okay?
Is it tangling the wires again?
It's a bit too empty now.
I'm back!
I did my task!
Alright.
We did it.
Oh wait, there was nobody.
Okay.
We should be really safe.
We're so safe.
Let's go.
I hoped.
We're at Resident Evil.
Oh, now it's Resident Evil.
It's Resident Evil 1.
Yeah.
Jill!
Look out!
Look out, behind you!
My berry sandwich!
Berry!
Nice!
I was gonna tank this.
We can destroy the box, god damn it.
There you go.
This actually looks like the Resident Evil house, not gonna lie.
The Wesker Mansion.
Yeah.
Do I think I live this?
Yeah, I was gonna say, do I live this standing in front of that?
literally stood in front of like two shot dude status is that it sucks the clutch plate is cracked i'm gonna have to take out the flywheel hey bear then pull the drive shaft sure just fix it man just fix this roger that i i can do that oh my gosh you're so you're so mean to him wow he's annoying why are you so mean to him he's just trying to do his job wait what you plug it boom i did nice nice that's a no-no hole nothing should nothing should come out only go in why don't don't say such words in front of my cigarettes please all right oh hey those are some nice paintings we should seal them It's like in that war.
In gears?
Yeah, in gears.
You know, like back then, people would just like rob historical items and just bring it home.
Put it in museums and stuff.
Isn't that fuck?
Anyway, I love the British Museum.
I think I'm blocked.
Wait, he destroyed my fucking thing!
He destroyed my cover.
That's fucked up.
Oh wait, that's you.
No, someone's behind you.
No, I shot you.
Why are you shooting me?
Because you look like a locust.
What can I say?
How is that racist?
What are you trying to say about the locust, huh?
No, that's fucked up.
Are you trying to say something bad about the locust?
Wow, now that's racist.
Oh My game like paused I was like did it crash?
Nice I need that two bullet Why is it not homely Jesus?
Holy shit you need more you need more That is no longer Dude wait can we break this?
What's in there?
It's just nades You need one right?
And a fridge I don't need nades?
Are you out here?
Yeah, kind of new sweet Sweet.
This is your area.
Yeah, I got it.
All right, your turn.
Clear.
I'll take it.
Oh, it's too quiet.
Too quiet.
Hey, man.
Shut up.
Oh, sorry, baby.
Whoa.
Where are we going?
Where we go?
We're tremor.
there's nothing we can what was that yeah he's gotta keep moving is there more of that like more of those uh what's that oh it's a sniper yeah ladies first
thank you yeah such a gentleman i know what not wise i know like what Oh, this.
The non-obvious wine seller.
Hmm.
I wonder which one I could read.
Oh my god, look.
Look, it didn't drop all the wines, guys.
You just picked it.
I thought you were going to pull it or what.
No way.
We found it, guys.
APCs online.
What?
Where'd you go?
Where did I go?
Oh.
What?
I got TP'd behind you.
I was like, where did I go?
I don't think I was supposed to do that.
I was just as confused.
They were like, you were not supposed to stand there.
Watch this.
They won't know.
Check your ammo.
How would they know?
That's a lot of footsteps above us.
Oh, crap.
That's a little scary.
Don't worry, they won't know.
you're shooting revolvers look see you didn't know here they come get the what why are these guys not building you don't know they're only like they're only AI to you see look at that I might die no you're fine am I am I so healthy yeah the The moment they come out,
boom, there you go, drop them in the back.
They're like, they don't see me.
You're so healthy.
Peak.
We're loading.
I need.
Oh, nice.
See, he did it.
I told you.
That's the fastest door opening.
That's the strat.
Cut scene.
Nice.
Our little movie.
This is where we get our bathroom break.
Commercial break.
All right.
We're so safe.
Jack, log in and see what you can find.
Search his Google history, too.
All right, on you.
All right, it's time to grab a popcorn.
This is a five hour cutscene.
This is the five hour cutscene.
Yeah, this is how they pad out the time.
They pad out the next two hours of this game.
What in the fuck?
I take it that qualifies as an update.
to get the job done.
More than enough.
Then let's get out of here.
How the fuck do we?
I can't.
The files are too big for this bandwidth.
What the fuck?
What do you mean the files are too big?
You can get an SSD.
Yeah, grab an SSD.
How many terabytes do you need?
I thought we were living in the future.
Give us your location.
Front of the middle second story.
Hurry up.
We're on our way.
How is that possible?
okay chapter six out of six discover how many acts were there again i don't remember six of no this is chapter six of act four six acts right six acts so this is gonna be act five place we're almost there
i love the shotgun what the was that seriously nice now nice let's move out run away man chill man you're so behind keep faster just crouch run I'm literally just walking behind you and I'm around your speed oh what he just closed the door on us behind you oh shit can you just do that close the door in front of us yeah he legit just closed the door like they can close doors yeah it's messed up they have opposable thumbs i'm jammed i'm reloading i know you were jammed but i still wanted to reload just for the fun of it okay i'll get the two front holes you get the back okay never mind i'll get the back holes you get the front holes okay someone was not getting the front holes Oh shit!
Oh yeah!
Yeah, he was like, wait, you guys are supposed to be dead.
I thought I'd be ammo in there.
I could have sworn that door was not shut.
Wait, did they like...
No, maybe they had...
Some of them that were carrying like flanks and nails and just hammering it up.
I fucking would close this one.
Yeah.
How far do we go?
second story something something wait they close all the doors that's up i know they're like carpenters too defend the front of house god damn it why is there a cutscene
just kill all the females and then we win keep them out of the house they can't make more locusts if all the females are dead like the the big blind ones right the one in the cave yeah they look like a finger or something it's like it's like kill the kill the queen ant and then we win some bugs attack they reload i have to it's a boomer what the is that is not a boomer that is shoot the front maybe that's a oh i think he's gonna oh yeah he made it he made it he made it they're oh they're coming in now they're they're in we didn't stop him no i don't think we stopped him i don't think i don't think he can be stopped everybody can eventually stop all right i have a lot of animals out i'm on my side arms need ammo what defend from are we done burning there must be like one guy that's still alive somewhere probably stuck AI again oh fuck it's boom it's a boom boom yeah it's boom oh my god I almost died there I had five people shooting at me oh god I can't see where he is he's like I can't
ping but he's right there yeah very helpful boom I hear that.
Oh, my God.
I legitimately can't peek.
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
Oh, there's an ammo here.
No!
Nice.
He literally boomed at the moment I peeked.
Don't worry, I got you.
Okay.
Ooh.
He's very slowly walking for it.
Very slowly, very intimately.
Oh my god, there's so much illusions!
Here you go.
Don't worry, I'm right next to you.
We can just pick each other out.
For fuck's sake.
Boom.
The boom guy's not dead or just more.
Um, there's, I think it's another boom guy.
I tried my gun, so...
Alright, I got him.
There's one guy left here Just look just shoot him in the corners back of the house back of the house back of the house what?
How do we even get to the back of the house?
Yeah, I don't have a map.
We don't have Kim Oh shit.
Oh, wait, I have a shotgun
Chase him chase him chase him.
Oh
shoot there's ammo here there's ammo here engine there's ammo here damn i'm i'm good for now oh you're good just refueled i'll just pick it he has a weak ass nigs shit shit yeah i opened it i found a way oh okay fine don't use the door that i just opened it's not even open they barricaded it i don't know that i opened it i i can see it from here you literally north see i opened it look shut up look what you're talking about there was no barricade i know what you're talking about what the look at that look i'm gonna prove to you look at this okay yeah and you said i didn't open it i told you it was open i know are we at the back of the is this like a house i assume so like a center of the house oh my god oh i might be dead
boom i i filled it up you're welcome look and i opened the door and i filled up the hole i think there's a guy running towards you right now oh no he's right here oh my god he's like like sliding over his guns all right here you go are we done are we like that way we're supposed to go yeah there's more there's more there's more you're supposed to come back down from the door i open yes oh my god it's cpc me too where did you go i don't know it's cp me behind now oh no it's boom man the one that i fixed
got a headshot oh my god my vase not my vase nice nice i think that's it right we got 40 seconds we gotta go holy um you not see me running oh my god there's another boom guy get to the oh my god um um i need help i need help yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm on your six i need help okay i'm on your six
look yeah Wow I triggered that cutscene for us oh shit what the fuck what the fuck is that it's a bigger boom guy the Vegas they made a mecca
why are cutscenes so loud like they don't have a separate audio it's like it's like the the lord of rings ogre if the lord of rings is set in like medieval times was in like 2099 or some it's just resident evil 6.
it's like cyberpunk lord of the rings this is delta we're out and we have the mapping data i hope one day they do a re they do like a re-imagine of Lord of the Rings where it's set in the future.
I'll see Gandalf messed up.
I'm gonna eat my sandwich.
Nice.
What kind of sandwich?
We're not fine now.
A bread sandwich.
Whoa.
Gandalf with a glass.
I would like to see that.
That's just Star Wars.
Yeah, Yoda is Gandalf.
Gandalf with a Glock.
Yeah, we'll see Gandalf of a Glock.
Let's get this bridge down.
No, no, I want to see Lord of the Rings set in 2025.
No, set in 2000.
In 2020.
Is this the way?
There you go.
I want to know how the Lord of the Rings gang going to deal with COVID.
Is that Pepto Bismol?
Yeah, that's Pepto Bismol.
not having a good thing.
Oh.
No, you don't.
You piece of...
What even happened?
A bird's closed down a little bit.
It's the locust.
Wait, oh, wait.
Who is Mark again?
They're not that important.
Oh, it's the guy that's not coal.
It's the guy that's not coal.
The coal tree.
the bridge is jammed then we got unjammed seriously stop getting pregnant like what the hell is the population of yeah i know like what's the consensus here like what is the mortality rate and the birth rate who is making them are they like how fast do they grow very fast There's like four of us,
and we've killed so many of them.
But, oh my god.
Oh, come on.
He hide.
You hiding again.
Boom.
What?
He wears a helmet.
How is he, like, still alive?
I shot him in the head, I think.
Maybe he's wearing a helmet.
No, he's not.
If he's wearing a head, he should die.
Oh, now I got a headshot after hitting him, like, seven times.
Grenade!
Oh, my god.
I missed my one There you go That sounded clear.
This is bullshit.
They were waiting for us.
They know what we're doing Control this is Delta.
We're stuck at an open drawbridge.
We need to restore power to this sector.
Please advise
Rat if they know where we are
Roger that Dom you're with me Baird, Cole, you two guard the A.C.
Someone's last round playing with ping.
Yeah, I'm playing on Indonesia ping right now.
So I'm like 200-ish.
Ready to move as soon as the power comes back online.
I'm at 200 ping.
Two.
Maybe.
Like 220 at least.
Parade it down.
All right, then.
That's why shotgun is so good.
Oh, whoa.
What was that?
I didn't like that.
You go first.
I did not like that.
Don't worry, you're the main character.
You're not going to die.
Main character doesn't die.
Main character never dies.
I don't like that noise, Rook.
You sounded just like your old man back there.
Yeah, well, screw my old man.
He thought it could prevent this war.
And look what happened.
Yeah, well, now his mapping date is going to help end it.
Yeah, plot armor.
Your player was.
I don't think he'd appreciate the...
I have...
Plot armor cannot be repaired.
Oh, no, they're gonna have like those like cloak ninja one got enemies now The ones that would like stab you in the back What is it him?
Oh, he's trying to eat No, no, wait He's so white Is he dead?
Oh, he's dead.
I was gonna say it Oh, shoot.
Oh, shoot.
What is that?
Oh, that's him Alright, let me grab this gun That's just sad that's actually so sad like whoa oh what the fuck i didn't get here oh my god they come from behind us okay i okay okay now that we know okay it's less sad now it's less sad i will now never feel pity for them i think we are sad now what the yeah we're sad then we go forward why did we just stay there yeah we're just like surprised my house okay over here i think oh that glass is broke on its own yeah this is a those glasses where's the where the where the is that lad lord i'm grabbing my my shotgun out now he he closed the door on me again bro they closed the door on me twice door on me twice oh this guy oh my god he already barricaded look at how much he barricaded don't fucking he closed i don't know he fucking brought he like moved it's over here by the way tangent is over here yeah not only did he like close the door on you he put a cold ass clock in front of the door how are how prepared are they like where did they
find this oh god nice shot what the heck i like how it did an animation when it broke the glass but the glass was already broken yeah like why is the glass broken before they jump out like what the like such it's a surprise it's like they won't expect this yeah they've killed all our brothers and sisters but this time i'd be the one to stop all of it what the is another door i open there but i don't know if that's important where over here what the is that noise i think it's you know it's a big ogre mecca guy all right are you sure it's not a berserker
What the fuck?
What the shit?
What the fuck was that?
That's freaky as fuck.
Yeah, I did not like that.
I did not like that.
They started screaming.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he has so much armor.
Oh my god, I might be down.
I'm down, I'm down, I'm down, down.
Nice.
I literally tanked that entire shot for you.
Boom.
Nice.
That's right.
We have the hot girl now.
Oh my god, a poor man.
I wish I was what I would have said if he wasn't a goddamn disgusting locus.
What can I throw this?
A cave well?
I can make the shot.
Okay.
Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
Nice day.
Look, it wasn't about...
It's the wind, okay?
I didn't account for...
The wind was blowing against the current.
The current?
Yeah, yeah.
It was blowing against the current, so that's not my fault.
It was a...
There was a Typhoon 3 warning, okay?
That would have made it in if it wasn't for the Typhoon 3 warning.
But it's this way.
Yeah, it's pretty windy, huh?
Yeah, it's very windy.
It's crazy how windy it is.
wait is this not what the fuck is that where's my actual gun what do you mean your actual gun is I actually exchange it for the wrong gun where do we go in the left to that like alley yeah there's no alleyway here what the fuck what the fuck um what wait what the fuck
How is he here?
Oh, there's an open door.
Oh my god, they just opened that door after we killed that one guy.
Not a one, not a door, a window.
Oh, die, what the fuck?
I thought you fucking wrestled him, what the fuck?
That's right.
Oh, he closed.
What the fuck is going on?
I don't know what's going on.
And opening something, what the fuck?
It just closed by itself.
They're like, all right, now you can progress.
All right.
Come on, keep that door.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, never mind.
What's the void of the gig?
Yo, what's up?
Got to be close to this power.
Sorry, hit 9 p.m.
I've got a close shot.
I think so.
Just up ahead.
Across the park by that old theater.
Move out and get Jack to start the repairs.
We'll meet you at the power line.
Oh, there is a lot.
Nope.
Shit, that's a lot of enemies.
Where are they?
There was a lot.
There were a lot in the freaking...
Yeah, there was a lot.
Yeah, where are they?
There was a lot.
So dramatic.
Oh, got rid of...
Oh, yeah, no, there is a lot.
Oh, wait, never mind.
There's one guy in the turret.
I'm just gonna kill the regular guys.
Boom.
Well, I'm going to move up.
We got to move up.
Oh, you don't have to.
He has a helmet.
I'm going up.
Cover.
Oh, nice.
Oh, reload.
Nice.
What's the point of me shooting them?
You're just going to headshot them.
That's all I'm going to say.
Oh, shit.
What happened?
He attacked a bench and then the bed, it exploded through the bench.
It was fucking crazy.
It actually boomed.
There you go.
Now I can kill him.
That's fucking right.
Boom yourself.
What the fuck?
We're shooting the turret guy because he's too busy looking at you.
Oh, okay.
Did you need him?
Yeah, I did.
Oh, crap.
Oh, there's food.
We've killed two before.
It's not that bad.
That's true.
I got a turret this time.
Okay, he's just looking at, oh, nice, okay.
Holy shit.
Yeah, these guys were not that bad.
Oh, what the fuck?
I'm inside, by the way.
Don't worry, I'll activate the cutscene.
Okay, you gotta kill him.
Never mind.
We have to kill him.
Oh, we have to?
Yeah, I think so, because the door is not opening.
Unless it's like the main character has to opening it.
What about?
Okay, there you go.
That's a clear music.
There you go.
God damn it.
The clear music.
Dude, a power line.
So can we now open this door?
Boom.
Okay, I fucking knew it.
I was like, it has to be like main character buff or some shit.
Player two is not allowed to open the door.
He's like, you're not player one.
You're not, you're not the main character.
But you're dumb, man.
What's your status?
I want to be dumb.
Yeah, but you're bending Yeah, but I want to be Dom Yeah, but Dom isn't in any famous TV show What's that?
Oh my god What is he gonna do?
Oh Cole train Is Cole gonna die?
Totally insane Yay, we live At least we're not players three or four.
Because you're not like them.
Oh, they made a hole.
Don't worry.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, I threw one of them.
I died.
Yeah, I saw.
I did it for the cause.
Yeah, that's right.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, you threw that.
Okay, so we're out throw another one.
I mean I threw what?
Wait, whoops.
My shizzy Okay, I'm gonna throw another one.
Boom, okay.
I don't know if I'll die for it, but I threw it.
I did it.
I'm a hero.
I'm coming over.
Fucking shotgun.
Okay, I guess that works too.
That works.
Last guy is to our left.
And now I aura one.
another cutscene i feel like it's like we fight for like five minutes and then we get like a six minute cutscene that doesn't sound good i think we can still make it in time but if we don't we're gonna spend the rest of our lives running from like this i think it sees us no we're fine see yeah there's a in front of you see we're fine this bridge is built very strong yep very very strong bridge i believe you don't worry it can hold like 800 tons and this monster is 799 tons so as long as there's no as long as that there's no extra one more time we're fine one more time we're fine yeah And another cutscene!
Brumag's gone.
Thank you very much.
And we're headed back to the power line.
Shit!
I thought they lost him.
Okay, now we go this way.
Oh, we did it.
He's no longer on fire.
Oh, I thought there'd be like so much secret in here.
Over there!
Over where?
That way?
I'll just run over.
Oh, that way.
Oh, okay.
They just closed it.
Oh.
Oh, no.
They just destroyed a random structure.
Yeah, we're fine.
See?
It was over there.
I was going to like that structure.
Now they destroyed it.
Yeah, like and subscribe.
No blood-free motion.
Oh, no.
It can be anywhere.
That's Jack.
Yeah, he's Jack somewhere.
Yeah, there's there.
He's, look, that's Jack.
Where is Jack?
grubble where wait where's the grubble oh over there boom only have one need left
where are they i closed it supposedly yeah like that's like the last guy live yeah where where yeah you see that okay yeah i do all right sniped them back yeah if they peek Is he slowly walking towards us?
Oh, it's him.
Oh, that's not a boomer.
No, that's like poor boomers.
Oh, shoot the legs!
I'm shooting the legs!
It's still coming!
I don't think it's working.
That's right.
His feet is very sensitive.
He has sensitive feces.
Oh, look at him.
His feet.
What are they called?
You know, someone must have drawn fan art of this guy's feet.
What?
You know, like...
Speaking in front of my cigarettes.
You know, there's like...
You know, there's like a website where like, it's like a directory of all the streamer feeds.
I remember fart cakes.
What the fuck is fart cake?
Oh, is this like cake where they sit on cakes?
Literally in the game, you just pay people, usually girls, to fart on cakes and take a video.
What the fuck?
There's no way there's no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No.
I wish I was kidding.
How did you know about that?
No comment.
Wait, how did you know about this one?
This then?
No comment.
Who's had us that time?
Hmm.
No, no, I'm curious.
How did you find out about that?
What the fuck?
What am I?
Get out, okay.
Oh.
We're alive, but I doubt we'll not get back to doing too much.
Troll, this is Delta.
We've repaired the power lines, but there's a Brumac here.
Please advise.
Over.
Sick my hips.
We'll never know what Anya wants to say.
Anya, do you read?
Oh, is that Jack?
Oh, Jack.
Yeah, that's Jack.
It's me, a cedar.
Ugh, I'm close.
Looks like we're on our own and we need you know about the one where oh my did you see like the new the new Eagle baiting streams Where they white baiting there's like okay, so there's this new trend that I saw and like it showed up on my timeline And it's where like they chatters can pay to control little robot cars with cameras on them to drive around the girl Is that fucking crazy?
Did you hear this?
Business is business.
Yeah, there was a Twitch meta where like streamers would literally be like, oh, hey, if you pay X amount, you can access these cars with cameras attached to it.
Someone's like, oh, that's like six months.
How did you know that?
How did you know how long ago this Twitch meta was?
You seem very well versed in when it started.
Oh my god.
Business is business.
I want to go left side.
Which way do I want to go?
You want to go left?
Yeah, I want to go left.
I'll check the main hall.
Dom, head upstairs.
That's not good.
I was just like, I was there at ground zero.
This is not good.
Wait, I'm just by myself.
There's like two guys.
There's like, there's a cedar.
There's like two guys on a...
I don't like that.
Oh my god.
this guy has a sniper uh-huh I am kind of confused on how to get out of here right now I shot him in the shoulder um give me a sec I have another person I'm dating right now what is he fucking look away so insane reaction where is he oh my god he's looking at me what the fuck are you talking about oh no I'm getting shot by like multiple man there's like two of them shoot down the wall Shoot down the walls?
Where the fuck is that?
I am trying my best to shoot at the turret guy for you.
They just look at me one millisecond away after.
You see, dude, he's looking at- Okay, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Oh my God, I got it though, I got it.
There's another one.
There's another one?
Yes, that's why I can't move, there's two of them.
I don't need no.
Okay, I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him.
Oh, he's off the turret.
Yeah, he's off the turret.
You go shoot him.
All right, I'm moving forward to my area.
Oh, wait.
I have to just stay here.
Wait, there's a sniper over there.
What the fuck is shooting me?
The cedar's the problem, though.
I'm trying to get the sniper.
I'm trying to rotate.
My rotation is a bit awkward.
wall like this what wall i'm trying to figure out what you said but i shoot down the wall that i'm gonna shoot down the snip the three fucking sniper that's just there don't what just happened oh you died what just happened i don't know what just happened i need
Oh.
There has to be a back door.
Let's split up.
I'll go.
Okay.
I realized I was supposed to do something for you.
I see.
That's...
That's right.
Okay.
Aid.
Come on.
Don't worry.
I got you.
For real this time.
Come on.
Let's see where I'm throwing it.
Yeah, I got one.
Oh, I got you.
For real.
Oh.
I got, I don't, I actually don't know what happened.
Yeah, exactly.
It's the, it's the flying thing.
I think, holy crap.
Like, I don't know what happened.
I actually just exploded.
Yeah.
That's what happened, I think.
I wish I knew what happened.
That would have been pretty interesting.
He's still alive.
Yeah, you're off the sniper.
Yeah, I have three snipers.
Yeah, there's like a lot of snipers here.
Like it's either I'm taking care of the sniper or the flying thing.
all right i'll deal with the sniper then okay this ammo is lacking all right well i'm dying dying i'm trying to cover oh my god all right shoot down the wall where is it oh where's the wall which one's the wall he's still looking at me he's like shoot down the wall even what wall man what's the wall support i don't know what it is is it that it's a wall it's a wall support it's supposed to look like a pillar or something markus this stage shoot down the wall what does it look like i don't i don't know like what oh i see it i see wait what is it i think it's something like this it's either of those yeah i see it all right oh i see it i see it that's not a wall that's not even a wall that's like oh that's the wall okay okay never mind that's the wall that's the wall never man okay we figured out we figured out what the wall was we're smart we're pretty smart what the Fuck out of these guys!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There we go.
Wait, where's my shotgun?
There it is.
How do I get down now?
Oh, what the?
How the fuck do I get down?
Hell.
We learn what a wall...
V-tubers learn what walls are.
As a TV.
Never seen them.
Never seen one.
Yeah, we never seen them before.
I've never seen one.
I've never seen an actual law before.
Wait, what?
Where do I go now?
I'm, like, stuck here.
I'm trying to clear out the area here.
Oh, are we supposed to clear the area now?
Okay, that makes sense.
I don't know.
There's a lot of people with a bow in front of me, and, uh...
Okay, that makes sense.
I was like, am I supposed to help you?
Like, there's legit a lot.
I want to get on the turn, but at the same time, I am kind of scared.
Oh, my God.
The sniper is just shooting me through.
cover where is the sniper oh there i got the sniper i think nice there you go oh i jammed my sniper rifle boom there you go okay there's so many armored i dropped my other gun too so i don't really have long range anymore i'm gonna get on this thing brrrr there you go
all right that should be all of them i also do you see my gun at the bottom i accidentally dropped it yeah i see a couple of guns yeah you see the gun i actually drop yeah i see a couple of guns whoops we kill them all i hope so because i can't go anywhere
okay i'm i'm at the back door oh shit okay never mind i can go somewhere they literally just open the door for me they open a door for you yeah why why do they open the door for you when they close the door for me that's i'm a nice person that's actually where you clearly have made some enemies i have no enemies okay i need you to turn that yeah yep
Yay!
Do I need to turn it again?
Let's go!
No, it's my turn and turn.
Oh god.
Now I turn the wheel.
Oh my god, this is so janky.
Yes, it is.
See, they're live!
Why are they blind again?
Are they sun sensitive?
I think, yeah, I think the lights are too bright.
control this is delta do you read
we need more we need more satellites the only way we can catch that for the 5g where's the where's the military funds yeah i think i think we got a hundred we got cancel we got cut funding for education we got all the we got triple the defense budget this is for freedom USA.
We're not even USA.
All right, let's see.
We're going to go this way, I'm pretty sure.
Okay, Canadian.
We go up or bottom.
I don't know.
I'll check out.
Oh, down was just the floor.
Oh, it's just that.
You mean the ward?
defense budget we are defending for freedom we are defending freedom that's why it's the defense budget I might be dead he's literally running straight at him okay um how you got this right I don't know maybe boom boom what the fuck is that the cedar it's below us it's below us the guys below us
holy shit he is so loud it is bro he's like in my he's laughing he's giving us ASMR all
right hit this guy love this guy oh god boom we're booms now why didn't I leave the turret the turret was literally just there.
Wait, kill the cedar.
So we'll improvise.
I kill the cedar.
Oh, shit.
Okay, you gotta defend me.
I don't know if I can kill them.
Shoot the tanks.
There's a tank right there on the left.
Oh, should I see it?
Did I do it?
I don't know.
That does.
What does that do?
I don't know.
Leaking gas pipe.
We just let... Can we shoot the gas?
Is it?
Oh, the truck!
Okay.
I see I was gonna be like what are we gonna do make him die from methane gas like are we wait what it died instantly like that with a truck and a fucking gas we need to shoot it like at least three times why the fucking hammer of yeah I was gonna say why the fuck did we use the satellite rays if we just get gas in cars I think there's an embezzlement going on bro yeah I think we might be embezzling these bugs I don't think we need the ray of look as cool you don't understand this that looked cool as hell you're close to tim gad central energy but it only works that day what's the what's the point it doesn't look as cool but it works only at day we already spent like six billion dollars on the satellite we already spent the money we have to use it true then because then people would like think we wasted our money so we're trying people that we did not waste anything just notice you can zoom in with the revolver what the fuck it's like when you know like how um companies like they get
too much money for the spending they like they try to spend all them and uh they didn't spend all the money they just buy random shit so to make sure it doesn't the budget doesn't get cut yeah yeah it's just like that we gotta spend as much money as we can so our budget doesn't get cut so our budget is justified seven yeah exactly we had seven billion dollar excess so we had to spend it on the satellite all on satellites no communication satellite just just a straight straight who's fancy laser pointer it's a really cool fancy laser pointer though really cool yeah it's very cool oh that guy was tired he was like resting on the trash
Oh, God, I got blasted in the face.
What a name.
I'm dead.
He, like, arrowed me.
There's a name.
I wait.
How do I get to you?
Just run over.
Press E.
Don't worry.
You'll live.
Don't be a pussy.
Are you being a pussy right now?
There's a guy pushing me or gave me a second.
Boom.
Nice.
someone was being a pussy you are what you eat sometimes okay res me res me res me res me run away I'm here I'm here I'm just role playing as classic DPS player where's my heels oh my god bad support low bad heels bad heels us support doesn't res me bad support our team is not even here whoa whoa where am i what what the fuck i need to grab water real quick i'll be back go grab water please oh my god so this is how my morning starts
oh man i need more coffee I could use more coffee
This morning for you Yes It is currently 10 p.m.
Guys It is 10 p.m.
I ran out of water I'm here Ran out of water Yeah I gotta stay hydrated You know Stay hydrated for war I got I got like Two bottles of two liters Jesus I had a liter But like I drank it all during the stream earlier.
Oh, I might be dead.
Get ready to res me.
GGs, no heals.
Sorry, I'm uncapping my water while you fight.
Don't worry, I'm hitting my cigarette at the same time.
Alright.
Alright, I'm ready.
Don't worry, your carry is here.
Hell yeah.
Yeah.
nice oh i shot our teammate in the back nice what the fuck where are they coming from where are in the front of us why the fuck is he over here yeah like i could have sworn i passed there and looked over that side there's nobody there's two doors let me check this side oh my god it's a boom guy boom it's a fancy toilet for fuck's sake we killed like 20 of them what does he mean
like um um um there we go I was like he's getting closer Tengen whatever that was
whatever that was what the fuck was he doing act five we were we were we've been in act five for a while are we all right here we go you're swinging that green i don't think this shit reaches yeah i don't think so either oh my god oh my god where the fuck is this little guy okay don't worry i got the cover of this table okay i don't have an angle at all don't worry about this couch don't worry this couch does not give me cover now i have this this car is fine it's a it's a soft cover it eventually worked in the end can you kill that one guy on me it's right I got it there nice hell yeah we did it
yeah just got TP'd again oh my god what the fuck he just literally came out of the elevator and shot me I was not ready for that wow yeah see i told you that's literally what happened to me too they're suddenly using shotguns holy oh doesn't matter that's good
no not yet they're missing though um um um one guy.
I'm gonna just try to stun him.
I feel like revolver is stronger than sniper during those fights.
I can't tell.
I genuinely can't tell.
He's like, I headshot him, but he didn't fucking get to die.
That's so confused.
There you go.
I don't think you know.
That's a good question.
I headshot him with a sniper twice and then I did.
Oh, the arrow got me.
Press me.
Oh, the arrow.
Yeah, I got arrow too.
I got arrow.
The fucking arrow.
God fucking gave arrows, man.
The fucking arrows.
Oh, my God.
We have to do booms again.
Oh, it's these guys.
We have to do the shotgun guys again.
What?
Yeah, I generally can't tell.
Like, what the fuck was that?
Like, sniper reloads is just really slow.
Okay, I'm just...
Okay, he can't aim.
That's good.
Okay, he's not going my way, so I don't know.
Kill one.
Boom.
I shot him in his butt.
I shot him in his ass and won.
This is for freedom.
Let me hit my cigarette.
All right.
I triggered it.
Good thing you hit that cigarette.
Yeah.
Oh, you're not dead with a single headshot.
Two headshots and they're still alive.
That's what I'm saying.
I think it's because they're wearing helmets.
Three headshots, probably.
I'm pretty sure it's a helmet.
that came out of it so like it's hitting it is a bear's pushing I saw someone to our right is still there yeah he is I got him oh shit the shotgun is harder now isn't it it doesn't like what the happened did they scale yeah they scaled like I could have sworn shotgun was like three shots until we die yeah it just i think the chapter like at this chapter it just got harder this just goes from bad maybe they're older they're more experienced with the guns control we're at tim gad central energy copy that what's your status just moving we're in door kicking bro like seriously can't you look at their legs they gotta use it for something they worked hard for that they worked hard on those goddamn
Whoa, what the fuck I know like what the fuck it just started us right into like the gunshot Like not even bothered to put us in a cover I was hitting my cigarettes All right, we gotta go up He just blew himself.
I wish I had my rifle.
I missed that Oh, there's two of them.
Yeah, there is one got one that's just been hiding over there
I Think he has the rifle is he here's the rifle yeah, he does oh thank god.
I fucking need to get rid of the shotgun That's the point is it?
No, that's not it.
No, it's this one there you go There were two different guns there.
Is this the yeah, it's the nice actually one of that But how do we what what oh it's the other side?
Oh, it's this way.
Oh, jk I saw a gear on the other side.
Oh Oh I live.
I don't know how but I live
Hello Please die.
Oh, I got the wrong gun.
Okay, I'm gonna go back and get my gun.
You got this right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Where is it?
Yeah, there it is.
All right.
I'm back.
I was wrong.
It wasn't the stranded tapping the grid it was these guys What's who?
All of it.
Tell me you can fix it.
I'm working on it.
Damn it, Jack, we have a circuit.
But you'll need to turn off some panels up there.
What are we looking for?
Panels, you know, green glowing eyes.
I can hear you screaming across the room.
Oh, hey!
What the fuck?
Why are you?
How the fuck did you get here?
That's right.
You heard me, so I came back.
The fuck?
That was freaky.
oh he's back he's still alive it's a big crocodile i wonder who the i wonder if that's a baby or like like an adult i think that's a juvenile you know is that baby i imagine how big the mama is where is he running to i don't know he was he was on a mission to go somewhere he's going somewhere all right who is grave oh i can't open it i'm not player one oh we're not supposed to go there no i can't open that wait oh the window the window jk window never mind i thought it broke it's a bullet proof when the do we go oh valves oh oh what am i getting shot
What the fuck?
What is he doing here?
Here I got him.
Alright, he's...
He has the high ground.
And now we can do it.
Oh, the door's open.
Where am I getting shot from?
Wait, where did you die?
Where the fuck shot you?
Oh!
Okay, that's what shot you.
No, I was shooting him.
He was not shooting back.
There's so much ammo over there.
You need ammo?
Yes, I knew.
Literally right here.
What the fuck is shooting us?
Is this a sniper right here?
I fucking accidentally picked up the sniper again.
Oh, my God.
Where did the sniper come from?
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
I got my gun back.
I'm happy now.
I'll wait for you downstairs.
I think they're coming.
It's just, we gotta go through the door.
Nice.
Stand by.
I'm gonna open a door for you.
Bye.
Open the door for us.
There's one last panel in that room.
Transfer it to me.
Holy shit, this goddamn bullet sponge.
Oh my god.
You dead yet?
No, I'm still alive.
Nice.
I think we gotta do this here.
I hear more footsteps.
Me too.
I hear like our guys shooting something.
Like they're across the room.
Oh, it's, oh, there's nays.
Oh, god, nays.
I have zero.
I have nays.
I have two.
Are you sniping?
I hear sniper.
No, no.
That's not me.
That's what I'm saying.
Who's sniping on our team?
I think that's cool.
Like someone is sniping for 20 years.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
now what power levels are good but we need to jump the transformer who is shooting in a sniper is it cool it's cool man you mean we're stuck uh what the hell you mean we're stuck uh yeah unless you can pull something out of your ass yeah i think i think it was cool i think you finally hit a shot something big enough to fit between those things out front think i just solved our problem dom think we can get the broom active chases hasn't been a problem up till now open the back door for us oh is that necessary yeah like what but what what that was a cutscene okay that was the cutscene there it is now what now we piss it off what how the I'm not gonna piss on it.
Oh my god, it hit me.
Hello?
What's up?
Oh, wait, wait.
I got the...
Nope.
Goodbye.
I need...
I need Rez.
Rez!
Target those arm guns.
Oh, arm guns.
Rez, mercy!
Okay, nice.
A guy is BTs.
I'm shooting the arm guns.
I'm shooting the right arm.
I'm trying to get covered, but there's no cover here.
That's why he's chasing you.
I'm shooting it right now.
I'm shooting the right.
Okay.
It's destroyed.
Oh, he's not looking at me so I can't shoot the right.
I'll shoot his feet.
Oh, God.
I literally tried to run to the...
So he...
Oh, kill the driver.
There's a driver.
I don't have an angle.
There's a dude on top of it.
I mean, I can shoot a link still.
There you go.
It's crouching.
He's crouching.
He's limping.
Come, come, come, come, come.
I got his feet.
Kill him.
Boom.
Nice.
Okay, let's roast this thing.
Run to the Transformers.
Where?
Over there.
the access road the fences are transforming robots in disguise transformers robots in disguise
robots in disguise
he'll be okay a million dollar worth of many manufacturers why did he bike fight the power pull is he stupid i mean i don't know it required a driver so perhaps and i thought the food in prison's not all right we won't have power in new york for five years because of that bridge power is restored and we're moving out marcus we've lost control of the train now you'll have to catch it as it passes through tim gad station Roger that Jump on a moving train And try to recapture a bomb That sounds easy This day just keeps getting better and better Yeah,
Dom That seems so easy That's like the first thing you learn in military training
Yeah, train go boom Yeah Get bomb, jump off train You do drills for that every day Train go boom What difficulty are you playing the hardest one Are we?
Yeah.
I don't remember.
Up where?
That don't make sense.
They just appear out of thin air.
Where are you looking at?
What are you looking?
Oh, okay.
Okay, I see them.
I was like, where is up?
Gamers don't look up.
Where is up?
I literally can't even see them on my angle.
I'm really a walk boy.
Where is up?
That does not like compute.
Yeah, yeah, like shape your fingers like an owl with both of them maybe.
Oh yeah.
Where are you?
Oh, that's a bear.
They cover.
They open a hole.
Where?
I don't see no hole.
Oh, this, they come from that.
What the fuck?
Oh my.
Hey, Rez.
Hey, Rez, what happened?
Rez.
What the hell happened?
What the hell am I getting shotgun frog, man?
You're deaf.
Where am I getting shotgun frog?
I know that's what I'm saying.
They're still shooting me.
You would have fucking shot me.
Oh my god, there's a sniper.
Oh my god.
Yeah, it's a sniper.
I was like, where is the area?
sounds like okay jesus these guys are so annoying oh i hear something on our left like there's a hole there is it was there's a hole there's a god
literally fire in the hole i'm just oh my god where am i getting shot at
somewhere i'm also getting shot from places because there's no like because it's like they show up inconsistent covers yeah all right where how do we get in the train how did you get in train here's a small wooden gap
come on coltrane no no they're not It's okay.
We'll remember them.
We'll make a memorial for them.
Goodbye.
That's their fault, honestly.
That's not our fault.
Oh, it's the train level!
Oh, that's fun.
Hell yeah.
Alright, you heard that?
We got it going.
I'm gonna run at it.
don't run at it there's a there's a yeah don't run at it don't run at it there you go that's fine oh yeah are they all coming oh there's a guy with the bow yeah i know that's why i said i was literally shooting that guy there's another bow man here i feel like these red containers should blow up when you shoot at it like right i'd expect Oh,
it's leaking smoke.
Yeah, it's leaking smoke.
So I should be able to blow up this entire train.
What?
Bow.
What the fuck happened?
Bow man, bow man, bow man to the left.
If he shoots from behind us, it activates too.
Which I don't know.
Feels illegal.
Yeah, I was going to, I'm just going to wait for you to break.
I'm just meleeing a bow guy, man.
You know what?
Me too.
Their armors aren't worth it.
ow ow ow ow ow okay meleeing does not give you an eye frame yeah yeah i don't think so okay don't worry i'll do my turn all right do it okay keep covering me though nice yeah let's do i'm dying as well and nemesis not good move in oh nice ammo all right i'll go to you see you don't have Jack.
Oh my god, Jack.
Oh, we got to defend now.
Great.
Now what?
Are you kidding me?
Resurker!
Where?
What?
Here?
I don't know.
Oh, my.
Snoo Snoo Snoo.
Yeah, my reaction exactly.
Wife, Dad.
Don right now.
you can't not without those nemesis thinking this guy fine we'll go to plan oh yeah there's no sun now what's plan b what what oh okay i think it's the gas tank i think i think it's gas tank i think that's why it's leaking i think it's the gas thing yeah i think it's the gas tank i yeah i think i think it's gas tank time all right that's why we can walk because she's blind
It's not working.
Kind of working.
Koopler release.
Where's the Koopler release?
Oh, did we fuck up by going back here?
Oh, it's here.
Oh, we need to release the switch when he's on the car.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here, here, here.
I gotta get her over here.
Like he charges.
Go away.
We'll just shoot her.
Get the fuck over here, man.
We'll get over here.
We want Stoostoosto?
Come on.
Let's lead him into the further back.
Okay.
Just a safe, you know.
Go, go, go, present, present,
I exploded.
What?
Why did I explode?
What the fuck that noise?
Now I'm player one.
To be fair, I thought it would give us a cut.
You get like a cutscene bump.
That's what I thought.
That's what I thought there was going to be.
Maybe there's going to be a cutscene.
I thought you would get a cutscene bump.
Where you just jump over.
I didn't think you'd actually die.
I'd explode.
You actually exploded.
That's crazy.
Like how to like how to fuck.
Is she going to run?
Oh, okay.
She doesn't run through that.
She doesn't know how.
Okay, she's running.
Okay, okay.
I'm heading over.
You better come over or you're gonna... Hold on.
Hold on.
I'll lure her to the further back.
You better come over.
I'm waiting.
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
Look at me.
All right.
Wait.
The sap, the sap.
Okay, now.
shit the fucking rag dog yeah you right dog what the fuck is this for then like this red thing ew oh gross we never what the fuck is that oh is that the seedling did them just oh we gotta go we gotta be quick and where i'm crouch running i'm crouch running obviously that is how you can run faster Pick this up.
We're on our way.
Ooh.
Oh.
Yeah.
Grab some ammo, too.
Where are they?
Oh, they're just here.
Oh, they're ceilings, too.
What?
Wait, where are you?
Oh, you exploded.
I don't think we're supposed to be outside.
Yeah, we don't think we're supposed to be outside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come inside.
Watch the windows.
Oh my god.
They're zoning.
Oh, they're zoning.
Oh, um, we gotta...
I'm dying.
Oh, I got you.
I got you.
All right, here we go.
I'm gonna rush.
I'm in.
We gotta stay inside.
Let's keep moving.
You have a shotgun, do you?
Yeah, I do.
I do.
I'm running.
I've made it.
Yeah.
good news you've got chain guns on the river we got chain guns that's such good news
oh whoa oh that was not good news that was dope give us the chain gun on my ammo where there's a ladder oh over here why did you have the ladder oh it's one at a time for safety for safety for One at a time for safety.
That's the ugliest damn thing I've ever seen.
Oh, I got one too.
I'm missing every shot.
I mean, this friend is kind of ass.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know if I'm hitting.
I am.
Okay.
I don't know if I'm hitting.
I don't know if it's scripted.
Yeah, it was scripted.
Don't worry.
It was scripted.
You were meant to...
not hit him oh my god oh my god they're like serpentine now they're left right left right they're w-a-s-d there's they're maneuvering they're tap strafing they're tap strafing what the fuck what the fuck what oh they're riding them holy shit what happened to the rest of the just exploded what what does that sound the wretches on you what the power oh we got a run run oh wait it's not time we're fine oh it's these guys oh it's like snowy ones oh Okay,
how the fuck are we going to progress if they keep exploding?
Yeah, on a choke point.
Yeah.
Is there ammo here?
They're like, Nate are Nate spamming us.
Where are you?
Where did you go?
Hold on, I need to find out.
Where are you?
Oh, my God.
I'm out.
I'm out, I'm out, you know?
Oh, my God.
I was getting fucking flanks.
button reverse press the button oh shit reverse what's the button for boom got another i don't know what just happened there i don't oh hello you're live dude i'll go inside you go outside no way i'm not going outside we go okay we had a plan it was ammo it was just ammo
You wish nothing but an ammo.
Hey, you needed ammo, didn't you?
Yeah.
Shoot the riders.
Okay.
I got him.
I don't got him, but like, I got him.
Jesus Christ.
They're so tanky.
Oh my god.
Chris!
Let's keep these guys.
Let's keep these guys!
I'm going!
Go away!
We have a pattern!
we have a pattern all right that's it let's just go fuck it pattern she said i feel like we shouldn't like it didn't matter about killing them where in front of us jack open his door jack where the fuck is jack jack's right on top of you oh he is oh where oh come on what oh Oh.
Okay.
He got those, right?
Jesus, they're like really right on top.
Yeah.
Ow.
Up where?
Up where.
Please point at the place.
I'm just gonna, I'm gonna start using my regular bullets.
I'm not a shotgun.
like they just come in one by one not even that scary thank you thankfully the only coming one by one it's like a little few more seconds two more seconds we'll pick you up as soon as we plant the data so put that 40 seconds oh shit we're at your time go go go just dodge just dodge Don't worry,
I'll remember you.
Don't for God's sake.
Don't worry, I'll remember you.
20 seconds.
Do it.
Oh, my God.
You, I can't press a button.
It won't let me open that door because you're dead.
That's not fair.
It's not fair.
We'll pick you up as soon as we plant the data.
Whoa, yeah, baby.
Come on, man.
Okay, I'll definitely need a shot.
for this part.
Player one.
Player two can't be a hero.
That's messed up.
Player two should be allowed to be a hero.
We have to do.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Button.
Oh my god, this is actually not fair.
I can't believe you got button privileges.
What?
Open!
How many buttons do I need to press?
I'm just a sidekick.
Never the hero.
Dom is always the hero in my book.
I can't quit you, Dom.
Let's do this.
Can't quit you, Dom.
Oh no.
Oh, yeah, I do.
Right here.
Oh, it's this guy.
Oh, him.
It's Kro-Man.
It's for avenging Kim.
Hell yeah.
You don't like the sun.
He's a gop.
He's a gop guy.
You're not allowed to look at the sun.
Wait, how do we kill him?
Do we just shoot him?
That's a kill Ram.
His name is Ram?
The hell?
It's not a gop.
goff name that's a pussy ass name sorry to anyone that's named ram
i'm shooting him i'm engaging oh god there's a flying thingy maybe if i do this ow what the oh jack was getting shot by crows what I didn't even realize crows were on me.
Oh, no.
Can we not skip this?
Oh, it's an unskippable cutscene.
Skips.
It's skip.
You can skip it.
Oh, my God.
How come you can skip?
I hate this.
You're shot by the fucking riders.
Where?
Oh, there.
Okay, I see.
Boom.
Okay, so we can't die.
what happened to the side covers i don't know i think it got shot at fuck i think we can't shoot it when he has crows on him right i don't know i have no clue he's shooting at me so you can shoot at him where the is the okay there you go what he attacked you with the crows okay that's illegal okay There's a chain gun.
Oh my god, I think that's it.
You go get the chain gun.
You get the chain gun.
Getting on a chain gun.
This is the only way.
Like, how do I get...
How do I get out...
I die?
I don't understand.
How do we...
How do I not get attacked by the crows?
State of light?
Where's the lay?
There's like some light...
There's like light lit up grounds.
of stuff oh i don't look at i look i don't look down yeah like we're literally standing on lit up ground right now you see like this oh yeah yeah oh i i see now ha ha i understand i feel like he doesn't take damage when he's like gross gross gross oh my god you're what happened
the crows so much what the hell happened there i got i'm just gonna stand next to you if i get crowed at least you'd come down with me i'm i'm gonna stay with you
oh crows crows crows crows you see me can't get me i'm he touched you're fine what dude why are I shoot Let me finish that guy in the fucking Boom I stay here
I don't think he takes damage when he has the crows on I mean it's red Red should be damaged I don't know No clue Alright I'll let you keep shooting what triggers the crows though like yeah see another crows are attacking um we're on the light we're fine i'm a little scared he's getting awfully he's getting closer he's getting very close to us there's no way i'll shoot us hey man hey keep moving keep moving okay i'm sticking to the light i think he sees you yeah yeah he's coming after to you i'll shoot him in the back okay he's coming to me now so i need to shoot him now it's okay he's shooting at me so you keep shooting him i'm gonna i'm gonna get the chain gun i'm out of ammo man okay all right i'm just see if i can i'm just gonna i'm just gonna chill here that's cool
the crows i understand it now i told you I have no nades.
The crows.
I don't know, man.
When are they going to give us the light?
It's the crows.
Okay, apparently it takes a lot less damage when he has the crows on him.
That's fine.
That's why we can shoot him now.
He has no crows.
Oh, jam.
Oh, come on.
Stop moving.
Okay, can our guy like shoot the light on him?
Like please do your job.
You literally don't have to do anything else.
Just shoot the light on him.
Oh, nice thingy.
All right.
You assume shooting.
Okay.
He's coming to you.
He's coming.
He's coming over.
You get ready.
He's shooting.
I'm getting shot.
I'm getting shot at you.
I'm gonna light.
Oh my god.
I'm on the light.
This is light.
I'm on the light again.
Okay.
All right.
I'm on the side.
No, no, no.
It's good for you.
Okay.
All right.
I'm behind him.
You're in front of him.
Maybe we can aggro.
What's the side?
all right he's definitely super aggro on you what's happening i don't there's so many more crows is he something more crows like what the fuck is wrong with you we're in the light all right he's looking at me free shot for you i'm almost out all right fuck sick this is my last yeah
let me just I'll just hide behind the cover oh god step into the light nice the light worked hey guys the goff didn't win against the Sun we did it we killed a man what would you get back what you don't mean that's right here we go Are you- what are you doing?
Oh, you're grabbing the bomb or the data.
Uh-oh!
The bridge is gone!
Wait, then why try to stop us if they know the bridge is gone?
Nice!
And we get to eat- we get free fish for years because all the fish will be dead.
Boom.
Oh.
Oh shit.
Oh, there's a lot of them.
Yeah, that's a lot of baby.
Holy crap.
I love eating fish.
That's radioactive.
That's polluted by weapons of mass destruction.
We actually finished it.
Oh my god, that was the end?
I thought there were six chapters.
I thought they were like, boys, we have to kill someone else.
Who knows?
I mean, I got an achievement, complete the all acts.
Job done.
But you have my word that we will rise again.
Yay, we did it!
There, but the queen is still alive.
do not know why we wage this war oh why we cannot stop oh is that the queen not stop why we will fight and fight and fight wait is that onya until we win or is that the queen and we are not dead yet it's it's just a human oh she had like the same on she had like onya's face model so i thought it's the same oh he's back he knows it's over he oh my god why is on oh my god he walked closer to me he he knows he knows he finished the game it has been done he knows That's fun.
That's fun.
I hope one day they'll actually, they'll actually remaster Gears of War 2.
Alright, I'm gonna grab him.
Grab him.
Boom.
But Gears 2 is not on PC yet, right?
He has been grabbed.
He's good right now.
Right.
Oh.
That's fun.
I don't need time.
So wait, are they gonna...
Make two, three, four, five.
I mean, I don't know, because all they do is just remaster one, like, four times.
Yeah, sounds about right.
Sounds about right.
I don't know why they don't do it, though.
Maybe they lost.
Maybe it's like, what was that game where, like, they lost the files for the game so they could never remaster it?
There was like, does anyone remember what game that was?
Oh my God, that's the cold trade.
Is this copyrighted?
It's fine.
I don't really care.
Can I...
Wait, it's just, like, a little higher revenue.
I need all the money I can get, man.
In this economy.
It's almost Doggy's Dog World.
That's true.
Oh.
Destiny 2?
Oh, is it Destiny?
They had, like...
Oh, so they couldn't do anything to the game.
They couldn't remaster it.
because they they lost the game they lost like the actual project files that's i know the same for some movies too they can't remaster like some animated movies or like not anime some 3d movies because they lost the project files and stuff yeah they i lost their they accidentally deleted the game files shit happens right yeah so they can't they couldn't like do anything about it That's why we don't get Gears of War 2 and 3 Because they don't want to admit it They don't want to admit they lost the files Totally That's why they remastered 1 like 4 times This is the 4th time,
right?
That they remastered it?
Probably?
I don't remember how many times they've done it I remember seeing it like Xbox One I know it's been like Xbox One And like 3rd time This is the 3rd time they've done it And they always forget to, not forget, they always like make sure to not include two and three.
Right?
Dad.
They just do it.
They just, what do you mean you lost the files?
Just find them.
Yeah, I legit just downloaded it.
I downloaded it.
How you, how you lost the file?
I downloaded the game.
Just Google it.
Just Google the files.
Somewhere, somewhere in pirate base.
Oh my god.
You know how they're like always make backups and they never do they don't I don't think a lot of people do backups man I don't Wow If anything happens to my PC Oh god Oh god It's the fun of it the gavel.
It's the thrill of it, you mean, for fucks it.
It's the thrill, you know?
I like playing close with fire, you know?
I want to see how high I can fly to the sun.
I'm actually concerned now.
It's okay.
I will never lose my skin suit because Celia has all the files so I could just because I know because she backs up her.
I have responsible people that back up their work and I'm not one of them.
You you pay to be lazy you know how they're like when you're like um you know how like um uh when you get your PC like fixed or something or like you want to change something or PC they're like you should back up your files just in case I took my PC to the shop a lot of times and I think I've only I've only done that once I don't I've only done it once.
Honestly, I find that nice that they actually suggest you to back up some stuff.
Because some scummy PC shop here will legit just like reinstall everything without your consent.
Wait, really?
I think like that's a lawsuit.
Oh, what's that here?
What's a lawsuit?
You know, that's like without your consent, you know.
You gotta have consent.
Yeah, that's crazy.
man yeah one day I'll learn how to back stuff up one day you just back up yeah one day I'll learn I feel like I feel like I I think like all I need is just like what I just need like an S like an external hard drive right okay to be fair I do have an external hard drive but they have like it has like the last time I've like I said the last time I've like saved like in point five I didn't back up I just like saved like important files in there was like I think like two years ago that's the last time very important yeah very important to forget about it me couldn't be me I had fun I had fun playing gears of war that was a good time good time tangent it was nice playing with you again hopefully they made the second game for real though I hope so I've God.
God damn me.
I never like, like I said, I never grew up with, like, I only watched my dad play Gears of War, so I don't even really know the plot of the game.
I remember playing the first one, but then I never bothered to continue it, so I wouldn't know what to expect.
Yeah, like, I knew about the, like, I just knew, like, I just knew they were called Locus, but that was it.
But I didn't really know the general plot of the game.
All it matters, I want to play Dawn.
I love the chainsaw gun.
I want to play Dawn.
never be dumb i want to be never be him i want to be dominic santiago why do you want to be dominic so badly he's so cool how is he cool he's like he seems like a little bitch also is there an after credit scene or like are we like watching i don't know i i skipped the fucking wait you skipped the credits i said i i watched i mean i went through like It's probably 70% of,
yeah, I don't know.
I don't know if it's repeating.
Yeah, I thought it was like...
The music stopped, and then I feel like I saw the Coalition logo at the first time.
So I'm like, you know what?
Maybe it's done.
You're not allowed to diss or avoid...
Why is this...
Okay, okay, what's up with Don?
Okay, what makes Dom...
Dom?
What makes him...
I can't say much, but we've got to play two.
and three what has he done to earn your respect guys because like oh because like right now marcus seems a lot cooler you wouldn't get it you wouldn't get it you gotta be there at two and three he's a man's man he's a he's all right i guess i guess we'll find out in like five years when They released the Gears Award,
too.
You're going to have to play two and three.
You're going to like Dom.
I can't wait.
I can't wait for them to release two and five years and three and ten.
And then we'll finally find out what's up with Dom.
Has the credits been going?
Chat, has the credits been?
I think it looped, dude.
It didn't loop?
I can't tell.
Because, like, I saw the Coalition logo again.
And I was like, oh.
Is it looping?
i don't know i can't tell i don't know if there's an after okay it's the third loop okay how the fuck how okay there you go i thought there was an after credit scene i've been like waiting for that i it's like the old time ages after credits weren't exactly popular like three times before I noticed.
I was just like, I don't know.
Oh, GG's tension.
GG's.
I have to be awake in like 9, 10, 11, 12, 1, 2, I need to be awake in 7 hours.
Go rest.
For Vexpo.
That's literally what I did for this collab.
I legit, I was like, oh, should I have to be awake at 7?
Yeah, I have to be awake at...
No, for me, I have to be awake at 3 in the morning.
Oh, God.
Yeah, so...
Sounds like my time where I wake up.
Because I have, like, the panel and then the meet and greet after.
So, like, it's like a three-hour day, like, three to four-hour day, depending on.
I don't know how many meeting greets there are, but it could be, like, an hour for panel and maybe an hour or two for meeting greets.
Like on that.
Yeah, so.
And then after today, today, I have a nice meeting tomorrow, too.
So, yeah, I'm going to call it here.
But GG's tension.
It was great playing again.
Maybe next time.
I don't know if you found any other fun or stupid games.
more and more yeah maybe next time we can actually play apex i haven't even installed the game yeah i think i i think i still have mine installed i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure because i i hate i hate re-downloading multiplayer games that are like a lot of get a lot of like you know there's like big lots of down oh i can't english right now that's a big file size because let's have wait like so long with my fiber internet you know hold 15 minutes it's so long like me when i installed warzone last night oh man it's just so hard to wait 15 minutes with my fiber internet it should have been five minutes you know uh man don't want to keep you waiting have a good rest all right i'm talking much you too take a nap and hit nap yeah and we woke up early for this been two hours i thought i thought it'd be four i thought it'd be three but like we finished it pretty yeah you're not just around there three yeah to be fair i started inting like halfway through because i was just like it doesn't
matter anymore like i was just like running into people in my shotgun i was like don't worry tension will rest me we punch through it all right tgs bye bye bye all right guys i'm gonna call it here thank you all for coming i hope you enjoyed today stream with Tengen.
I'm going to take a little break.
Like I said, I do have a panel and a meet and greet in the morning.
Well, not in the morning, at 3 a.m.
So, I'm going to head off now, and I'm going to rest my voice until then.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if it's still for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Oh, my God, he knows.
I don't know why he's so bratty today.
I think he's just like hungrier because like I fed him he like woke me up early to eat eat at like 6 in the morning And then he you know he demanded for food at like 3 p.m.
So now he's like extra hungry or some shit Anyway, I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye